for many years an enduring thread in the
tapestry of british politics has been
the assumption
that the labour party had the so-called
ethnic votes stitched up
immigrant families from the indian
subcontinent the caribbean and africa
would vote
center left on block but times are
changing
perhaps one in four are voting now for
other parties
and there are prominent minority
conservative cabinet ministers
and advisers i think that the labour
party have assumed that the ethnic
minority vote has always been theirs to
have and i think that's why it's come as
a shock in the last few years to see
that
uh people in areas like mine in sandwell
are starting to change how they
they vote and if there are no efforts to
try and address this then i think
general elections and years to come
could become very unpredictable
was it difficult coming out as a tory um
there was no option if i joked about
voting conservative i
was looked upon possibly even worse than
if i said i wanted to
you know be a drug dealer or a robber
bank
the public image of the conservative
party has certainly changed
twenty years ago the tories had no
ethnic minority mps
today they're 22 and a record number of
cabinet ministers
but are ethnic minority voters really
switching to the conservatives
or are the political leaders of the
party ahead of them professor maria
sobolesca studies voter trends
she believes labor has taken minority
support for granted
they have failed to promote their ethnic
minority politicians
to high office and they have had those
ethnic minority politicians available
uh in the back benches since the 1980s
and they don't really
um campaign in areas where ethnic
minority uh voters live
directly in some in some of these um
these areas so
yes labor definitely has a lot of fault
to bear here
back in 1987 diane abbott became
britain's first
black female mp she's still in
parliament
and convinced her choice was the right
one
and why did you want to become an mp
oh i wanted to change the world
and you know if you were black in the
80s the labour party was the party you
joined if he wanted to change the world
and i've not regretted it now on the
back benches she accepts her party
hasn't matched the tories with cabinet
appointments
but she predicts any switchers are in
for disappointments
the tories are not really going to do
anything
for black and brown voters on maths
so i think that the black and brown vote
for the tourists
um has a natural point
um beyond which it doesn't go how you're
gonna vote for people
that that all the time are rolling up
policies which are directed against you
as the government sets out to level up
across the country
no party should take minority votes for
granted
adam bolton sky news